Get ready for killers to be reborn and for your
childhood memories turn into nightmares, as 2023's
blend of horror sequels, reboots, and originals
are poised to blow gore-hungry audiences away!
The first horror movie coming out in 2023
is M3GAN, which is set to arrive on January
6 from director Gerard Johnstone and
writers James Wan and Akela Cooper,
as well as producer Jason Blum. Wan and Cooper
previously worked together on Malignant,
while this is the second feature from
Johnstone, who directed Housebound in 2014.
M3GAN also marks Allison Williams' return to the
horror spotlight after her chilling performance in
Get Out in 2017. The premise is refreshing
but familiar, as roboticist Gemma utilizes
her knowledge of artificial intelligence to
build a lifelike doll. It's reminiscent of
the Child's Play remake from 2019, but MEGAN
dares to shake things up by giving audiences
a passionate depiction of survival between two
people who deeply need each other. Of course,
Gemma deciding to use her M3GAN prototype to help
take care of her recently orphaned niece doesn't
go well, and the result looks to be a palpable
tale of technology vs. humans with horror tricks.
"I won't let anything harm you."
The prospects of a new Evil Dead movie have been
in the works since Fede Alvarez directed a soft
reboot back in 2013. Even before then, there'd
been rumblings about a new film for years,
with Bruce Campbell set to reprise
his role as Ash Williams. However,
the 2013 edition was billed as a "reimagining" of
the 1981 original, with Ash absent from the story.
Instead, the reboot focused on new
characters attempting to survive in
a cabin while supernatural monsters
seek to possess and kill them. Now,
Lee Cronin has taken on the task
of directing a fifth installment,
called Evil Dead Rise. The plot follows two
sisters, Ellie and Beth, who must fight against
flesh-hungry demons living in the deep pits
below Ellie's Los Angeles apartment building.
What makes the Evil Dead franchise so
refreshing is how it always aims to
reinvent itself. The 2013 version
proved itself a worthy entry,
so expectations for Evil Dead Rise
are high ahead of its April release.
Scream VI is scheduled to hit theaters on
March 10, with the story continuing right
where it left off in 2022's Scream, as sisters
Sam and Tara and twins Mindy and Chad are
attempting to put their lives back together
as they leave Woodsboro for New York City.
Scream VI has garnered a lot of attention
in recent months, specifically because of
Neve Campbell declining to reprise her role as
Sidney Prescott due to a failure to agree on a
new contract. It's hard to imagine a Scream movie
without Campbell, but we'll see what the new faces
have to offer and how fellow longtime cast member
Courteney Cox carries the franchise's legacy.
Cox doesn't have to do it alone, though, as she'll
be joined by the returning Jenna Ortega as Tara,
as well as series newcomer Samara Weaving.
This also marks the first film in the franchise
without David Arquette, whose character Dewey --
spoiler alert! -- died in the last installment.
"It's an honor."
By the time Insidious: Fear the Dark hits theaters
in July, it'll have been almost five years since
Insidious: The Last Key graced our screens.
Franchise regulars Patrick Wilson, Rose Byrne,
and Ty Simpkins are all set to reprise their roles
as the Lambert family for the first time since
Chapter 2 in 2013. And Wilson is also set to make
his directorial debut with this new entry. Series
creator Leigh Whannell is also back, with a "story
by" credit and also as one of the producers.
Fear the Dark is set to continue the Lamberts'
story, as Dalton is headed to college,
with the Lipstick-Face Demon returning to
bring his and his dad Josh's past into the
present. The last two installments
earned less-than-stellar reviews,
so here's to hoping that this go-round
can get the franchise back on track.
The Haunted Mansion that's set to arrive in
theaters on August 11 is neither a remake nor
a sequel to The Haunted Mansion
that came out in 2003. Instead,
it's another, separate adaptation
of Disney's classic theme park ride.
This updated version boasts a star-studded cast,
with Rosario Dawson, LaKeith Stanfield,
Owen Wilson, Winona Ryder, Danny DeVito,
Jamie Lee Curtis, Tiffany Haddish, Jared
Leto, and Dan Levy all on the call sheet.
The story focuses on Dawson as
single mom Gabbie and her young son,
who are hoping for a fresh start in life
when they move into a New Orleans mansion
that's possessed. And with Justin Simien,
who directed Dear White People and Bad Hair,
at the helm, the sky's the limit for
this new take on a Disneyland classic.
Five years after the release of The Nun,
James Wan is back with another installment
in this Conjuring spinoff series, as he
co-writes the story with Akela Cooper.
With director Michael Chaves at the helm, The
Nun 2 serves as a prequel to The Conjuring 2,
as it continues to explore the demonic
secrets of the paranormal entity Valak.
Taissa Farmiga returns as Sister Irene,
who is once again tasked with battling
Valak. Farmiga shined in her first
outing in the Conjuring franchise,
rivaling the work of her older
sister Vera as Lorraine Warren.
The Nun struggled to please critics, but
it made heaps of cash, raking in over $365
million at the box office. But a solid script
could certainly deliver plenty of unforgettable
frights this time around, so let's all plan
to get back in the habit come September.
"Amen."
There are some movies that are so legendary that
they can never be remade, and 1973's The Exorcist
certainly appears to be one of them. Luckily,
David Gordon Green's 2023 Exorcist film, which
is currently untitled, is meant to act as a direct
sequel to the original, as opposed to a reboot.
Set to hit theaters in October, the 2023
Exorcist is more than likely not going
to garner quite the success its predecessor
enjoyed 50 years ago. But writers Scott Teems,
Danny McBride, Peter Sattler, and Green are
all primed to approach this new installment
in a similar fashion as the Halloween trilogy
that concluded in 2022. The film will eliminate
all other storylines that have occurred
within the franchise since the original.
The divisiveness of 2022's Halloween Ends
may not bode well for Green and company,
but it will be interesting to see what direction
they take nevertheless. With Leslie Odom Jr,
Ann Dowd, and original Exorcist star
Ellen Burstyn all set to play key roles,
2023's Exorcist will do its best
to possess audiences once again.
"Is she gonna die?"
"No."
Saw has been a pillar in the horror
genre since its inception in 2004,
and every subsequent installment,
no matter how silly or illogical,
has brought something to the table
to satisfy its devoted fanbase.
The 2021 Saw spinoff Spiral found modest
box office success, and it felt inevitable
that a direct sequel would arrive, but
that part of the universe now appears to
be on the backburner. What Bell's return
to the franchise means exactly for Saw X
remains to be seen. John Kramer was supposedly
killed off at the end of 2006's Saw III , but
Bell has returned in various flashbacks
and dream sequences in the years since.
Even though 2017's Jigsaw, the last Saw film
with Bell, wasn't exactly well-loved by critics,
it managed to make its budget back ten
times over. Box office success in the
face of critical derision has remained
a consistency within the franchise,
so Saw X should be expected
to maintain the status quo.
Not too many upcoming horror movies have as
much buzz as Winnie-the-Pooh: Blood and Honey,
a grisly and gory take on the beloved children's
book character. Winnie-the-Pooh became public
domain in 2022, and with Disney no longer holding
the exclusive rights to the source material,
writer-director Rhys Frake-Waterfield set out
to turn a beloved cartoon into a nightmare.
The premise of Blood and Honey follows
anthropomorphic versions of Pooh and Piglet
descending into madness after Christopher Robin
goes off to college. The two woodland creatures
kill and eat Eeyore and attempt to wreak havoc
on humans after learning that Christopher is
now married. Naturally enough, this includes
attacking a cabin full of sorority girls.
Blood and Honey initially garnered attention
after a teaser was released in May 2022,
and horror fans and Disney adults alike should be
drawn to this reimagining. It's set to be released
on February 15 as an exclusive event through its
distribution company, Altitude Film. Whatever your
expectations regarding quality, Blood and Honey
should be worth seeing for the shock factor alone.
"Oh, bother."
The last Stephen King book to become a
film was the 2022 remake of Firestarter,
which was widely panned by critics. Hoping to
get the cinematic world of King back on track,
Rob Savage is helming The Boogeyman,
based on King's 1978 short story of
the same name that appeared in the
author's collection Night Shift.
If it stays true to its source material, The
Boogeyman should follow two sisters who are
haunted by a sadistic, paranormal
monster while grieving the death
of their mother. This is one of King's
lesser-known short stories, so Savage and
company have a promising opportunity to bring
prominence to an otherwise overlooked tale.
The Boogeyman is not set for a theatrical release,
as it's due instead for exclusive streaming on
Hulu sometime in 2023. With a budding young cast
that includes Madison Hu and Sophie Thatcher, as
well as a script from A Quiet Place's Scott Beck
and Bryan Woods, the promise is certainly there.
Adapting Paul G. Tremblay's 2018 novel
The Cabin at the End of the World,
M. Night Shyamalan is back
with Knock at the Cabin,
an apocalyptic psychological horror
film set to hit theaters in February.
The story of Knock at the Cabin follows a family
of three who are taken hostage by four friends
with a lot of demands as the world is about to
end. Tremblay's book is emotional, cutthroat,
and merciless. How Shyamalan will translate that
to the big screen is something to look forward to.
The book also offers a lot of commentary on
modern-day homophobia, so it'll be interesting
to see how that plays out in the adaptation.
Overall, it's a story about paranoia, enduring
love, and survival in the wake of disaster
and sacrifice. Many of the ideas at play in
Knock at the Cabin have been touched on before
in other horror flicks, such as The Strangers
and The Purge, but the apocalyptic element
should hopefully offer a breath of fresh air.
"The four of us are here
to prevent the apocalypse."
Ti West and Mia Goth had an incredible 2022
together. After releasing X in March, it was
quickly revealed via an after-credits teaser that
West had also shot a prequel at the same time.
That follow-up, Pearl, dazzled audiences even more
than X, and when it hit theaters in September,
it was then confirmed that a final film
would arrive in 2023 to make it a trilogy.
At the heart of the trilogy are two characters
played by Goth. X introduced the elderly Pearl,
who yearns for her lost vibrancy, and the
young Maxine, a porn star and the daughter
of a fundamentalist Christian preacher. While
Pearl follows the origins of the antagonist
who kills all of Maxine's friends in 1979,
MaXXXine will pick up after the events of X
to focus entirely on the title character. With
a 1980s setting, West is certain to deliver a
stylish time capsule of Reagan-era nostalgia
and another memorable performance out of Goth.
A release date for MaXXXine hasn't been made
official yet, and a more detailed premise is
being kept under lock and key. All we have
to hold us over for now is a short title
card teaser that ran at the end of Pearl.
Though the script is still in development,
the fact that West was able to churn out
X and Pearl within mere months of each
other suggests that we can probably expect to
see MaXXXine hit theaters before 2023 ends.